when you do meet fans what are the kind
of questions they usually fiery what's
the most common stuff people and ask
about um people always want to ask if I
do my own fighting or stunts um and
people want to know how I kept the
secret from How I Met Your Mother for so
many years keeping the secret how hard
was that um well when we shot it so nine
years ago we signed confidentiality
agreements David and I plays my brother
and it was kind of strange because it
was a brand-new show and you know people
hadn't really seen it yet and I didn't
know it was going to be such I knew it
was going to be a successful show
because it was so great but I didn't
know the see the secret was going to be
that crazy because we didn't know how
many years how many seasons it was going
to take to come out so it could have
been like the next season or like it was
and almost 10 years later um so more
recently by the end I was really flooded
by a lot of people saying come on just
tell me so that's when it got hard but
it wasn't that hard how much training
did you have two guys very finicky um
actually the funny thing is is nobody
asked me if I could do fighting or
stunts when I got the job um so I was
kind of just thrown into it uh so I
didn't really do any training except
when I got there we had a great stunt
coordinator and his name's Teague Fong
and he taught me a lot kind of as we
went along I come from a dancing
background so luckily it wasn't the the
physical aspect and learning
choreography was really easy for me but
um you know it was just a different
style so it took some time to to learn
that stuff also fighting for film is
very different than whatever that
martial art type is in real life so it
was also learning how to fight for the
camera angles and stuff so I kind of
just learned as we went some see quite a
serious show was there any sort of like
hardness on set oh yeah all the time you
have to be when you're like saying
someone assassin killed some you know
it's just like ridiculous if you don't
laugh all day long there would be
situations where we would be freezing
outside and we had to look like we were
just like oh whatever
and then it would cut and we'd all be
like this and like your teeth were
chattering and stuff we had some really
cold night shoots is there any
particular episode that was you fighting
for all was the most challenging um my
favorite and the most challenging was I
think it was season one or two when I
played future me and Alex because we
kind of had to decide what she would be
like in the future not just physically
what she would look like but you know
this this idea of her one idea of one
path that she could take so that was
kind of fun and then technically we used
a camera because I'm in a scene with
myself so technically we used a camera
that I had never used before and it's
basically you shoot the scene as one
person and the camera is locked and it
goes like this on the dolly and then you
have to do the exact same thing as the
other character and you have to act
against yourself which is not there and
then the camera is in a locked place and
does the same things to the film layers
like this so it was really strange and
unusual and challenging and I absolutely
loved it it was really cool especially
to see it afterwards and you know you're
talking to the air and then just see it
afterwards it all makes sense so it was
great how do you feel about how the show
ended for Alex um I loved it you know
it's kind of unfortunate that the season
was so short and we kind of had to like
rush it at the last minute but I really
feel like the writers did a good job of
trying to get everybody all the
characters storylines kind of finished
so with that being said um I was really
happy that Alex has had a a lot of
terrible tragedies happen to her and I
was really happy that it ended with some
happiness that she's you know doing
charity work and is in love and you know
there's actually something good coming
coming up for her yeah have you seen the
original
oh yeah the film oh my gosh yeah
absolutely
I have not seen the TV show no but the
film I'm a huge fan out is fantastic as
a vessel ever had any contact it's gonna
mean in the show of the Z no no he he
wouldn't even comment on it being made
um so I know that he's aware of it but I
don't think he you know we're doing our
own version of it so you know I can
understand it's his idea so I'm sure
it's like your own little baby you want
to feel protective of it so you know I
get it he's a real character you could
displayed ensure viewers love to jump
male or female uh Nikita
yes I would have loved to do birkoff
that was a great role I love how they
wrote for him
Erin Stanford did such a fantastic job
which by the way he's doing twelve
Monkeys for sci-fi I'm so excited about
um and I just I don't know they did a
really good a good job at bringing
comedy into his character so I'm really
that would have been fun what's next for
you then um I just finished a movie
called moments of clarity um that's a
film about two unusual friends becoming
friends two unusual girls and finding
each other it's it's kind of like Thelma
and Louise meets Juno to describe it and
it's it's got a very unique sense of
humor and a lot of heart and this woman
named Kristin Wallace it was her first
film she wrote it and starred in it with
me and she's really fantastic and I'm
really excited it's in that inning room
right now and about to start production
on a film called the escort where I play
an escort let's have to ask how are you
preparing for that I mean it's like I'm
not myself see quite a challenging role
over the mansion yeah um it's
challenging and it's strange because the
character didn't come from like an
abusive past she's not a drug addict
this is a high-class escort so it comes
with its own questions of you know why
this woman would choose to do that to
make money and so I've done a live
watched a lot of documentaries on women
that are very expensive escorts and and
all about their life and I don't know
it's a really fascinating world that I
hadn't didn't know anything about I mean
what surprised you the most about that
world has you been researching I was
surprised by how many women were so um
proud of their job um and then I I kind
of realized that I was judging them you
know and I was able to see a little bit
from their point of view of their job
and what they were proud of and that
they enjoyed it and that they were just
so free with themselves I don't know
it's a very fascinating point of view
and I'm really excited to play that part
in moments of clarity though two young
women obviously very different mm-hmm
who do you think you compared to more
and why I actually am more like
Kristin's character um Kristen plays
someone who's very optimistic and very
girly and always smiling and you know
I'm much more like that in real life and
I tend to play more serious my character
in that movie is a lot more dry and
sarcastic and it's kind of how Kristin's
character lightens her up and vice-versa
so we kind of in real life or I'll just
spin your favorite rope today I think
that they've all given me something to
learn from I guess Nikita was the
longest so me almost five years uh four
years so I think that one maybe is
closest to my heart and the hardest to
let go of but I'd say they all are
you